alles klar als klarer als klar alles
klar als klar klar hallo mein name ist
luca und ich habe früher sehr sehr viele
akinator videos hochgeladen und heute
schauen wir mal ob der akinator diesen
kleinen freund hier kennt das jetzt
fluffy fluffy candy event fluffy kennt
die eventuell aus einigen blogs von mir
danke dass das habe ich jetzt schon zwei
mal gesagt ihr kennt fluffy eventuell
aus den blogs von mir und heute wollte
ich einfach mal schauen ob der akinator
fluffy kennt ja gefangen ist eine figur
deutscher youtube naja sie ist teil von
meinem kanal also ich würde sagen er
nein ist eine figur real sagt ja also
sie ist real also
duffy ist ja hier aber sie ist jetzt
kein echter mensch oder irgendwie sowas
also ich würde eher sagen nein trägt
eine figur schuhe
fluffy hat nicht mal füße also hier auch
wieder nein hatte eine figur beine das
auch nicht hat mir flügel trägt eine
figur kleidung nie vielleicht sollte mir
echt mein t shirt kaufen weil du bist
ganz schön nackt stammt eine figur aus
polen die hier unten steht das la vie
tatsächlich euro
china kommt haye hat seine figur zwei
augen ja hat sie ist eine figur aus
metall nein da stand eine figur aus
einem spiel
stammte aus einem
ich sag mal ich weiß es nicht seine
figur kleine ja wer wurde die figur
durch youtube kann die ja-seite
wassersport schwimmsport surfen meine
figur eigentlich wenn nichts bekannt
diesmal also hier auch wieder nein dass
seine figur blau pink lila gelb
da stimmen wir haben wollen die frage
beantwortet ja gehört eine figur crafter
ja am laufen habe natürlich mit ja
beantwortet weil klassiker mir und dann
natürlich wer kennt nicht die nächste
frage vom akinator ist fährt eine figur
einen amg fluffy fährst du nun am g9
fährt platin nicht ewig auf holz dass
auch nicht fluffy ist auch keine flasche
auch kein hund und ja sie hat federn und
flügel
da bist du platt was sagst du dazu
als klar alles klar als cluster als klar
alles klar als klar
ich denke an fluffy lukas haustier ja
genau das ist richtig flagge wurde
bereits 620 mal gespielt
ist gar nicht mal so viel aber flach ich
meine wir haben natürlich auch noch nie
so richtig erwähnen und dann ist noch
nie gesagt mit akinator und so deswegen
freunde schafft ihr es auch fluffy zu
finden sache deswegen soll ich denn noch
hier besuchen
ökologie ist im hintergrund gerade das
ding ist halt so ein bisschen dass ich
schon sehr sehr oft gesucht habe mich
selbst auch wir gehen mittlerweile alle
irgendwie auf die millionen plays bei
dieser website zu
aber jetzt kommt eine challenge an euch
ich habe ich hier eine fernbedienung mit
der ich da hinten das licht anmachen
kann also ich drücke drauf das ist das
nicht anders nicht weil die ganzen kann
nicht an und drückt ihr wieder drauf
dann geht das licht wieder aus so und
diese fernbedienung befindet sich noch
befindet sich diese fernbedienung schon
mal akinator eine figur trägt keine
kleidung sie trägt auch keine weibliche
kleidung sie läuft nicht auf ihr bein
sie gehört konkret da ja sie ist nicht
aus holz sie ist nicht kriminell bist du
kriminell alter ist keine flasche sie
läuft nicht auf zwei beinen sie hat
etwas mit elektrizität zu tun sie wurden
nicht in hamburg gewohnt bei mir sie
reißt nicht viel die hatte das mit
elektrizität zu tun sie kommt dass
europa sie kann man nicht im fernsehen
sehen ein tierisches aussehen ja jünger
als 16 ja ich hab's nicht einmal
getroffen ja wir wollen im gleichen haus
gehört zu meiner familie genau wohnt im
selben haus passt in meine tasche ist
keine maus hat er was mit kraft das zu
tun hat nichts mit musik zu tun
naja gewissen form ist ein kleiner
computer aber die genaue fernbedienung
wird jetzt nicht erwarten also meine
damen und herren ihr habt jetzt eine
aufgabe uns war diese kleine
fernbedienung hier beim akinator
einreichen und dann im nächsten akinator
video werde ich dann diese fernbedienung
besuchen
weltfrieden nur wenige minuten später
freunde ich habe gerade bei der website
hier eingegebenen dass es kein computer
war sondern eine fernbedienung und das
erste was man dann angezeigt wird ist
lukas fernbedienung fernbedienung bieker
durchs bild wirft vielleicht doch
wir machen jetzt mal etwas ganz absurdes
und zwar versuche ich meine hand zu
finden also nicht meine hand aber
einfach irgendeine hand meine figur
wurde nicht durch youtube berühmt sie
ist nicht über 120 jahre alt sie ist
kein menschen die ist auch kein tier sie
hat keine zwei augen sie hat naja in
einer gewissen form schon sie hat dicke
finger ja spieler eine figur beim
geschlechtsverkehr große rolle hat meine
figur eine große oberweite nein ist oder
war deine figur tourende hafen männlein
hast du deine figur schon mal nackt
gesehen ja mag da eine figur die sonne
ich weiß es nicht arbeitet die figuren
trägt eine figur schuhen ein na dann
würden was man bis 2000 jahre später
ich klicke jetzt einfach mal noch fort
ein gehirn und kampf fisch was ist ein
kampf jetzt gebe ich hier ein hand und
kann jetzt auf abschicken klicken das
heißt hans und muss
an dieser stelle will ich das video
jetzt auch beenden das wasser das war es
jetzt hier vom video hier können jetzt
jemand den kanal abonnieren oder hier
unten mal einen schock aus schenkungen
jetzt findet ihr zwei andere videos und
belgischen abonnent zeit könnt ihr auch
die glocke klicken dann willkommen die
benachrichtigungen
[Musik]